it's very crazy yeah you could say that
again because chase Hudson aka lil
hoodie just tried to deny that he
cheated on his ex Charlie D'Amelio and
she shut him down hard before we dive
into the new drama here's a little
refresher I'm taking it as slow as
humanly possible okay before I pop the
question okay but we are very exclusive
and very into each other these two
announced their split back in April just
months after they started hanging out
and seem to keep it drama-free honestly
some fairy tales
right here sharing twinning posts on
Instagram about how they're still
buddies he's a really really sweet boy
cute right not so fast drama quickly
followed thanks to a few cheating
allegations specifically claims that
chase cheated on Charlie and slid into
Nessa Barrett's DMS even allegedly
sending her some not so safe for work
pics if you know what I mean at the time
Nessa was dating Josh Richards and Josh
he wasn't too happy about it and even
released a diss track with the help of
his pal Bryce Hall toxic act like you
pop in nope built like a chopstick yeah
it's not nice and all this brings us to
a since deleted tweet that chase dropped
last night quote all of this drama going
on is because I kissed Nessa when we
were both single yeah Charlie had
something to say about that and dropped
the damn mic then you shouldn't have
come over to my house after without
telling me Bryce Hall also responded
tweeting you're an idiot kid stay
softish which of course is a reference
to that diss track still soft dish you
saw that's when chase decided to accuse
approximately half of the tic-tock
community of cheating hmm no seriously
in another deleted tweet the 18 year old
wrote quote since all my drama has to be
put on the internet for the world to
judge me let's lay out everyone else's
oh man you just can't make it up anyway
chase wrapped up his
host talking about those pesky NASA
rumors writing the only person who has a
right to be upset with me is Charlie and
I'm sorry I hurt her we broke up and I
messed up by kissing Nessa but he wasn't
done
I am NOT sorry - Josh we are not boys
and we haven't been boys since he lied
to Charlie saying I had an STD six
months ago trying to get her to stop
seeing me oh it's awkward and it gets
worse Charlie hit up Twitter to respond
stop deflecting your actions onto others
because you can't take responsibility
chase want me to talk about how you
treated me throughout our relationship
or do you just want to continue to play
the victim I'm exhausted I'm mentally
and physically exhausted anyway et
recently caught up with Bryce Hall who
opened up about dating in the tic-tock
world specifically Charlie and chase who
started dating when they were both apart
of the hype house Charlie the most
followed person on tik-tok has since
parted ways with the house do you feel
like tick tock blew up when people
started shipping I mean I think about
like even Charlie and lo hoodie
initially do you think that was a big
part in your guys's pop norms getting
big is seeing who you guys were dating
and like feels so invested in the
personal lives
it was definitely a huge factor
especially because there was like the
hype of girls and then the hype guys
getting in relationships it's not like a
hype girl it's like a random like person
it was just like their another huge
tick-tock er I think that like drove a
lot of traffic to it
[Music]